[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning the us
army says
we will fix this that is a very powerful
message following a scathing report
and scathing is a word into leadership
failures at fort hood
the 136-page report describes a pattern
of command failures
sexual assaults and soldier deaths at
least 25 of those deaths happen
in this year alone 14 officers and
enlisted personnel at the texas base
were fired or suspended and
unprecedented action in the army's
history
now the report was commissioned after
the murder of specialist vanessa guillen
maria villarreal has been covering this
investigation
reports from fort hood when i was
private
i was in korea and i was sexually
assaulted by my nco emotional stories of
sexual assault intimidation
and leadership failures quieted a
stadium filled with thousands of fort
hood soldiers
i figure even if i didn't get justice if
anything i could help
not only females but other soldiers and
really anybody out there who's been
violated like that to speak up
and have people help them specialists
samantha pemberton and andrea byrd
shared their painful stories with us
both alleged they were assaulted by
members of the military
honestly like i'm here to make a
difference
majority of the females that i meet in
the military
have been raped have been assaulted
by military men their revelations
followed the army's long
independent review results the report
named nine major flaws within fort hood
and the army as a whole
among them the command climate at fort
hood has been permissive
of sexual harassment and sexual assault
and the army's sexual assault reporting
program known as sharp
is structurally flawed what do you say
to the victims
who did not have enough confidence in
the army to report
crimes like sexual harassment and sexual
assault i think that's the first thing
you've got to do
as a leader is step out to establish a
connection and let them know
hey look if it's not working right now
and you don't want to report it there is
somebody you can report to
call me up the numbers in this report
are staggering of the 507 female
soldiers interviewed
the review found 93 credible cases of
sexual assault
but only 59 of those were reported it
also found 135 cases of sexual
harassment yet only
72 were reported one of the things that
the soldiers at fort hood many of them
needed was to be believed
and that was what we did we listened and
so if any of them
see this i want them to know we believe
you specialist vanessa guillen told her
friends and family she was sexually
harassed by a fellow soldier
before she was murdered in april gehan's
family says yesterday's terminations are
a positive step but not the final one
they're asking congress to pass the eye
on vanessa guillen act
to change how the military handles
sexual assaults within its ranks
i ask the public that is watching this i
ask
everyone who hears about vanessa's name
or hears about sexual violence in the
military
or in anywhere to endorse the bill
the act i mean because this will keep my
sister's legacy alive
and believe me it will save lives
the army's criminal investigation
division was initially tasked with
investigating vanessa guillen's case the
report actually has 70 different reform
recommendations and a lot of them
focused on the cid division
and overhauling them in fact one of them
actually says that
investigators here at the army should
ride along with local law enforcement
which is a very
unique and outside the box way of
training them to prepare for any sort of
crime that happens here
on post tony all right maria thank you
very much we want to remind our viewers
that before that report was released cbs
evening news anchor and managing editor
norah o'donnell spoke exclusively with
army secretary
ryan mccarthy and the interview follows
a year and a half long investigation
into sexual assault in the military
including interviews with nearly two
dozen survivors and their families
victims told us their allegations were
ignored and retaliation was rampant
we asked mccarthy about the problem and
where the army goes from here
is there a sexual harassment and sexual
assault problem in the u.s army
currently the trend is going the wrong
way
and we're going to take some pretty
dramatic steps
in order to reverse this trend do you
think it's clear that
sexual harassment and sexual assault
that there's zero
tolerance for it in the u.s army and the
u.s military there is zero tolerance but
at times it does
persist the soldiers that we spoke with
served at
numerous army installations all across
the country
they expressed a real concern about
whether the
army can police itself can that be done
i believe it can yes you do think the
army can police itself this institution
when it has its focus its energy against
anything
i believe there's nothing we can't do
the command hasn't been able to do it in
the past these individuals have not been
able to
and they will be held accountable
correct and are there any additional
structures that you put in place
to make sure that commanders are held
accountable in the future
yes this is the message that we're
sending to every echelon below me
which is all of them that this is
unacceptable
as for the timing of all this change
secretary mccarthy told nora he wanted
to take action before
january when president-elect joe biden
is likely to appoint a replacement
because as mccarthy put it he does not
want to pass this issue to his successor
isn't that interesting yeah it is very
interesting i mean those numbers that
mirea
put up on from the report of the number
of women who said they were assaulted
it's just staggering
well i can't say enough about uh nora's
reporting and the investigative team and
the producers who worked with her
they've been working on it for over a
year and a half and kudos to
secretary mccarthy because he knew he
was walking into a bus saw i'm not
calling nora buzzsaw what i'm saying
there is that
she and her team have felt very
passionate about it he knew the
questions were not going to be easy he
knew he had some
very difficult questions to answer and
he still sat down and he seemed
to me personally agreed by it he talked
about having a daughter himself
but i still go back to vanessa guillen
and her family if the family hadn't
spoken up the way that they did they
refused to just let this
he was a leader here he didn't run and
hide when the reporting came out he sat
in the chair and he said we're going to
make changes and the fact that he wants
to do it before
january so it can be him and not the
next person is big and they are sweeping
changes the reporting here's already
changed